hey everybody don't mind my squinting
into the sun i am in sarasota right now
at a huge meeting
for rumble and locals and obviously i
had to do something this morning because
this joe rogan story
uh is exactly why i started locals and
exactly why we merged with rumble and it
is almost the culmination of everything
that i talk about on the show cancel
culture wokism the whole damn thing it's
it's like all crashing down at this very
moment it feels like there's a real
moment of truth
for all of us right now this isn't just
about joe rogan this isn't just about
one man
standing up or not standing up against
the system this is this is really messy
so because i'm not in studio uh live at
11 o'clock as i want to be today i
wanted to just shoot a quick video and
then i'm gonna drive across the state
and i'll do a live stream from home a
little bit later uh but this rogan thing
it's like look
this thing was gonna be messy from the
beginning right like when he signed the
hundred million dollar deal they took
down i think 46 episodes immediately so
he signed a deal and he took the cash
while he knew they were they were
censorious people and he allowed that to
be and that's that you can judge him for
that or not judge him for that doesn't
matter it is what it is now this thing
has been ramped up to the crazy level
because last week this was all about joe
rogan is spreading misinformation about
kovid right that's what this was about
and look how quickly in just three four
days how quickly the entire machine
morphed to joe rogan has said the n-word
and it's like nobody really thinks joe
rogan is spreading this information
that's killing people if we cared about
misinformation that was killing people
how about all the [ __ ] that the cdc and
the biden administration and cnn and the
rest of them have done nobody thinks
it's about that and certainly nobody
thinks that joe rogan is a racist of
course he's not racist meanwhile we have
racist people that are teaching your
kids the entire democratic party has
been infected by neo-racism so it has
nothing none of
it has nothing to do with any of that
what this has to do with is that joe
rogan became more powerful than the
corporate structure so you've got these
clowns on cnn this morning acosta and
brian stelter basically saying spotify
should censor the guy and it's like you
guys don't want him really censored
because you think he's bad you want him
censored because he's competition
and it's like man
enough of this [ __ ] if we don't
stand up now all of us this isn't just
about joe rogan he has to make a choice
as far as what he wants to do with his
life at this point and he has all sorts
of pressures i think he's got a wife
he's got kids who knows what his
pressures are and people say well you
know he's got the fu money so he can do
whatever he wants it's like you know i
know a lot of rich people and just
because you get a lot of money it
doesn't mean you say fu there was one
guy who did the fu thing with a lot of
money that trump guy and they booted him
off too
so there's a moment of truth right now
but we are all in this together and
that's why it's so fun for me actually
today i'm here
giving a big talk to all the rumble and
locals employees about how we're gonna
save this freaking thing
and it's like could it possibly be more
relevant could it could this
conversation all of the stuff we've been
talking about
truckers that are that are more powerful
than media
a comedian podcaster that's more
powerful than cnn
and the system's coming to crash down on
him and everybody else so stand up while
we got a chance all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna get out of here in a little bit oh
face is getting red i'm gonna get out of
here in a little bit i'm gonna get
across across the great state of florida
and i'll do a live stream later thanks
everybody
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell